[موسيقى]
وفي مذبحه بير سبع بعد ما نفذوها وحملوا
10 عربيات بالناس وفض شويه ناس كطار قوي
فراحوا ضربنهم النار ج موش ديان وبقوا
شايلينه شويه عساكر يشيل لفوق ووا موشي
موشي يا يا يا فرحانين اللي هم موتوا اسرى
عزل من السلاح انت شفت اه ايوه انا شفت
[موسيقى]
بنفسي
هؤلاء الذين تربوا على فلسفات الغرب لا
يحترمون عدوا ضعيفا والضعيف هو من له حق
ولا يصر على حقه ونحن لنا عندهم الف حق
واحد حق وما كنا بامه ضعيفه بل كنا احسن
امه اخرجت للناس سيقولون ها نحن ابناء عم
سيقولون جئناك كي تحقن الدم كن يا امير
الحكم قل لهم انهم لم يراعوا العمومه في
من هلك واغرس السيف في جبهه الصحراء الى
ان تجيب عليك الجماجم والجثث كيف تخطو على
جثه ابن ابيك وكيف تصير المليك على من
حكموك كيف تنظر
في عين امراه انت تعرف انك لا تستطيع
[موسيقى]
حمايتها لو كان لحبات الرمال في سيناء ان
تتكلم لم استطعت انت ان
تستمع كان ابطالنا الذين وقعوا في في
الاسر عام
67 ابطال هذا التحقيق قد وصلوا الى
المرحله الثانيه من بين مراحل ثلاث يحللها
بعين الخبير هذا الضابط
المصري المرحله الاولانيه كانوا بيقتلوا
اي حد يقابلوه وهم
بينفعوا المرحله الثانيه كانوا بياخدوا
اسره لغايه ما كملوا العدد اللي هو يقدروا
يخدمو يعني الطا يعني
طاقتهم الاستيعابيه
المحر الثالته كانوا بيبدلوا العسكري
ببطيخه شحنو في عربيات نقل اللي بتحمل
حيوانات بتتحمل خلاص مافيش بقى ادامي يعني
في استعمال ادامي مافيش بتعامل مؤاخذه
بتعامل كان حيوان
راكب فين
عسكري بيريح جسمه قاعد
مقرفص وراسه دي في وسط بين رجليه وايده
على راسه رفص وض على راسه وقاعد على يعني
الرووت دي فوق كده فعيل يعني معان عسكري
عاوز يريح جسمه يا دوب ان شايل ايه على
راسه طال راحت صايده لان هو في العالي راح
بلاش العالي راح صايده مات وقعد في فسانه
في
العربيه طبعا خلاص كله بقى اتلم وسكت
وقعدنا راكبين في العربيات دب بينا لحد ما
وصلنا بير
سبع يعني شويه راحوا بيرسب وشويه راحوا في
حته تانيه انا معرفهاش لكن شويه ركبوا
القطر حطوهم في القطر العساكر حطوهم في
القطرات في في في
عربيات الحيوانات ركبوه فيها لدرجه انهم
كانوا عدد كبير جدا كان بيتخنق جوه
العربيه
ا لا ده كان النقل بقى من سينا لبئر سبع
دي كانت كارثه يعني وبئر السبع 18 يوم 19
عمالين يجمعوا فيه قره جابوا 10 عربيات
لوري كبار حملوهم قره واللي فضل راحوا
ضاربين بالن وكان موسى ديان واقف هو ربنا
هينتقم منه برض لان ده قائد
ومسؤول لما نزلت من
العربيه كنا في وسط صفين من العساكر
بيضربونا
بالشلاليت وبعدين ب تبص تلاقي كحكه عارف
الكنافه الشرقي اللي ملفوف دواير دواير
دواير بصينا لقينا دواير دواير دواير
ملفوفه كده ا عباره عن بني ادمين نايمين
ام نايمين في دواير جنود مصريين جنود
مصريين وضباط و من كتايب اخرى من كتايب اه
ده كان مكان تجمع الاثره تجميع الاثره كان
دول بقى يمكن مثلا حوالي من 2000 ل 3000
واحد يعني 2000 الى 3000 حاجه مرعبه يعني
كميه مرعبه من البني ادمين
اا
وكشافات مسلطه على على الناس
و عمالين يضربوا الرصاص من تحت الفوق بحيث
ان مافيش حد يقدر يقوم
[موسيقى]
يقف في هذه الاثناء كان الذي كان يومها
لواء الفريق سعد الدين الشاذلي قد قطع
سيناء كلها في يوم وبضع يوم ب 1500 رجل
ولم يخسر من رجاله ومعداته سوى حوالي
10% وفي هذه الاثناء كذلك كان
الاسرائيليون قد تمكنوا من المدنيين
المصريين هنا في مدينه العريش ارتكبت
شراذم اسرائيل بعضا من اكثر فضائع فضاع
بحق الاف من العزل الامنين
هكذا يتذكر الحاج عبد الكريم يوسف الجعفري
الذي تطوع وقتها للعمل مع المخابرات
الحربيه المصريه واستحق عن ذلك واحدا من
اعلى درجات التكريم بقتل طبعا اه قتلوا
مثلا ملكيين قتلوه الملكيين يعني مدنيين
مدنيين وقتلوا جيش برضه نعم
قتر يعني اللي قتلوهم دول كانوا كانوا
مسلمين مستسلمين اه طبعا ضربوه بالنار على
طول لموا اللي لموه في العربيه بتاعتهم
واخدوه طبعا الله اعلم ودوهم فين قتلوهم
موتوهم ما نعرفش عنهم راح دوهم كم واحد من
البلد تقريبا يا حج تقريبا من البلد اخذوا
حوالي هنا في المنطقه دي حوالي 250 نفر ما
نعرفش وين راحوا لحد اليوم لا ما نعرفش
طلعنا بتاع 2 كيلو او ثلاثه خارج البلد
فجت علينا الطيارات اسرائيليه ضربت علينا
احنا فاكرينها ضرب انبيل لانها بتضرب
منشورات لان غالب الناس كانت ايه لابسه
مادري نعم فايام يعني انا كنت اعرف اق
الكتابه فكان مكتوب فيها
اه ارفعوا الرايات البيضاء وعودوا الى
منزلكم جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي لن يفعل لكم
شيء مسكوا الفرد
ا ادوه
ضرب ابعش عن
راسه ض امبارح يعني نعم يعني كانوا كونوا
تقريبا حوالي عن خمس ست عص او ثمان عص من
العصا العصايا التخينه كسرونا علي انا
بنفسي يعني وكوني بسجاره في صوره دهين
باينه لغايه
الحين بسجاره وادوني
لخز حجنه
عشان يعذبوني
باكتر مخز
قوم وبعص عليه دق على الطرابيزه مجموعه
كانت 12 عسكري كانوا ماشيين في منطقه
الميدان ومجموعه انيه كانت حوالي 17 واحد
17 عسكري برضو ماشيين ومنطقه فيها 16 16
واحد كانت كانوا قاعدين ك تحت الشجر شافوا
طيار هليكوبتر سلموا مسلمين كانوا مسلمين
يعني نزلت الطياره طخو هم 16 ك موتوهم
وقاعدين و1 واحد كانوا مايين مع الطريق
برضه رافعين رايات بيضا ك ماشيين على
الطريق لحقتهم دوريه اسرائيليه مسلمين ف
صفوهم طابور كده
ورموهم اخوهم ضربوهم نار
وموتهم في المعسكر الجديد بتاع بير سبع
جاه القائد بتاعه القائد بتاعه قصير كده
وبيمشي ماشيه جامده زي
النازي ضابط نازي يعني وبيلبس نظاره من
بتاعه الجستابو دي السودا خالص
و بينطق كلمات قليله جدا لكن بتتحول بسرعه
لقرارات فقلنا له يعني الدنيا شمس وبرد و
قال للضباط
خيمه ونعمل لهم دوره
ميه ميداني يعني عباره عن خيمه تتعمل
بحفره ونوصل لهم ا حنفيه ميه العساكر لا
ابتدوا يركبو قطر
بضاعه ما احنا بقى جنب السكه
الحديد ركبونا قطر بضع عربيات مقفله تماما
لا فيها لا
نفس ولا خرم ابره كم واحد في في العربه
الواحده العربيه الواحده لا يقل عن 200
واحد فيها او 300 واحد 200 250 واحد يعني
عدد حسنا ان احنا راكبين فوق بعضنا
مافيش تهويه فيش نفس وبعدها اخدونا في
عربيات عريانه مكشوفه معليهاش مشمعات
وقعده العربيات دي تقول بينا من بئر
السبع الى ال الى شمال اسرائيل الى منطقه
عتليت بالطول موقفين اطفال المدارس بازايز
مكسره يحدفوه بيه واحنا جوه العربيات طبعا
غنايم واخدينها فرحه اهالي بقى طلع علينا
اللي طلع علينا بالطوب واللي طلع علينا مش
عارف ضرب بقى فينا الله
[موسيقى]
ينور لما قربنا ناحيه بوابه عتليت كان
موجود عدد ضخم جدا من الشبان والشبات
واقفين استقبلونا بانهم بقوا يضربونا
بالطماطم
وعلب الحاجات الساقعه الفارغه ا ويشتموا
فابتدع في يشتموا في جمال عبد الناصر طبعا
وفي ام كلثوم وفي النبي محمد
وطول ما هو يعني شتائم شتائم عنيفه
جدا فتحت
البوابه
ودخلنا لاننا نفسنا في الجنه قاللك كل
اللي لابس مغزه جزمه
يقلعها ماشي قلعن جزمه لازم تنفس
بقى قاللك كل طوابير خمسات اللي كله خميش
خميش خمسات خمسات
كده
الارض في ناس بيقوللك الارض بفرشها بالرمل
الفراشيه بالبذل
المدبب بقينا نمشي على شويه على صوابعنا
شويه على نعج رجلينا شويه على كعب رجلينا
من البازلت اللي بيخش في رجلينا واحنا
ماشيين من المنطقه من سكه الحديد لحد ما
وصلنا المعتقل حوالي 2 كيلو 2 كيلو على ال
بزلت 2 كيلو على ال بزلت ده هل المنطقه
تصادف ان هي فيها بذلت ولا هم انت حاسس ان
هم ن لا انا حاسس ان هم معمول متعمد مش مش
محطوط كده لا ا كان هو قال لك الا مؤخذه
قلع الجزم طب معنى قلع الجزم يعني ايه
فكان في اسرى بقى رحت لقيت الاسرى كلهم في
المعسكر ده ا رجليهم دي بتخر دم في الارض
وهم ماشيين فطبعا اول ما دخلت قلعوني
لمؤخذه كان لمؤخذه لابس جزمه تقلعها وتمشي
على الشوك ده ايه ده طب ازاي انتوا بتمشوا
ازاي ع الشوك ده قالوا احنا ما احنا هنا
بقى لنا كام يوم واحنا طب ما بكلوش لا
عساكر مرميه حاجه فضيحه فيرو اخر النهار
طبعا الجوع بقى والبتاع عاوزين ناكل
فراحوا جاب لنا بنات شبه عراه يعني كل
واحده
معاها الزنبيل اللي هو المقطف ده مليان
قشر برتقان وبقى يحدفوا كل معسكر مطفين
قشر عشان ناكله قشر برتقان قشر برتقال
البرتقال يافاوي ده القشر بتاعه ا بقينا
ناكله كلنا
القشر عنبر كبير كده
فكان تقعد على البلاط طول الليل في
التلج وبالنهار بالامر تطلع تقعد في الشمس
طول النهار العمبر ده كان مساحته قد ايه
وكان عددكم انتوا داخل كان كل عنبر فيه
100 بس هو كان يعني ممكن يكون
مثلا كان مساحته حوالي 100 متر لان كان كل
واحد بينام جنب الثاني وده في نفسه بظهر
الثاني ما كانش ف مكان وكانت دوره واحده
دوره ميه واحده للثمن
عنابي حفره ترنش محفور قصد بعضيه اتنين
ترنش محفورين قصد بعضيهم وحاطين الواح من
الخشب فيها فتحات ونقعد كلنا قصاد بعضينا
نقدي حاجاتنا انت قاعد وشايف اللي قصادك
الشخص اللي قصادك شكله
ايه طبعا ده شيء مرعب جدا
مش ممكن
تخيل انك انت قاعد وشايف زميلك عمال يدي
حاجته قصادك وخصوص انها مده محدوده اللي
بيسما لنا فيها ان احنا ندخل دورات الميه
دوره ميه مكشوفه عباره عن لوح خشب كبير
قوي قوي قوي في خروق كده ولا مؤاخذه كله
بيقعد جنب بعضه وقدام بعضه ثم عنابر في
100 في يعني 800 واحد على دوره على دوره
ميه واحده
وحنفيه ميه واحده شربه ممان عنابر هي
شغاله كده من فوق وتحط بقك كده
وتشرب قيس على كده كل حاجه الاكل في الاول
كان يجيب الاذان بتاع الاكل ويسيبه في وسط
الناس تقوم الناس تهجم عليه اللي يلحق
ياخد ياخد واللي ما يلحقش ياخد خلاص
يجوع عيش
توست كل 12 رغيف كل 12 فرد ياخد
رغيف قطع ترنشات وكل واحد ياخد ايه نصيبه
من الرغيف في تطور يعني هو في
الاول عمل ضغوط شديده جدا عليك بحيث انك
انت تنسحق يعني يبقى في شكل من اشكال
السحق
النفسي الشعور بالدونيه شديده جدا فجا
دورنا في
الاستجواب هو بياخد الواحد يستجوب ويعرف
هو في سلاح ايه ويعرف درجه ذكاءه ويعرف
درجه
وياخذ منه عينه دم ويعرف درجه قوه صحته
ويعرف كل الحاجات دي بيثبتها عنده وبعد
كده يجي ينده في ناس تروح تتسق وتيجي وفي
ناس تروح تسقل ما
تجيش كان بيحط تصنيف تفصيلي للحياه في قلب
مصر طبع يعني جزء منها مخابرات عشان يبقى
عارف ازاي يتحرك لكن الجزء الاخر هو بيصف
الشعب المصري لكن فصيله الدم ما دخلها مش
عارف مش عارف همهم بالتجاره في اعضاء
الاسر وتهمهم رسميا لان انا عندي رمضان
محمد رمضان من البحيره كان معايا وكان
قاعد بياكل معايا اول يوم خدوه خدوا منه
عين الدم تاني يوم جه معموله عمليه هو
ماكانش عيان بعدها عملت مشكله وعملت دوشه
وقلت ازاي يحصل كده خدوه ما جاش هل سمح
ليك او لاي حد من من الاسرى
انه يتح حدث بشكل منفرد مع اي ممثل من
ممثلي الصليب الاحمر
لا ما فيش حد تحدث معاهم الا لما حصلت
المظاهره ا كان حصلت لي مشكله مع برض
المشاكل ورايا ورايا مع الاثنين الحرس
فطبعا احنا جينا متاخرين وكانوا طبعا لنا
معامله خاصه بالكرباج فجاه يتعامل معايا
فانا طبعا هو ايده طويله وانا عاوز يعني
العيش من الموت انا كانت ايدي طويله زيه
سبب بقى المشكله الكبيره لما جاه عسكري
بيفتح الشباك عشان يجيب ميه راحوا ضاربين
طلقه راح م طيرين ايه
دراعه خرجت كل العنابر الصفافير كله بلغ
بعضه خرجوا كل العنابر ال 5000
اسير خرجوا كلهم في
مظاهره يعني المظاهره دي بدات من حوالي
الساعه ت بالليل
تقريبا استمرت لحد قبل
الفجر شادين بقى كلنا مظاهره جامده
يعني المهم جابوا اللي قاللك بس يعني اللي
هي سكتهم
بقى اللي راجل ردبه منهم فحقي يعني
احتراما للراجل المصري برض في نفس
المنطقه اخوان القصر المصريين انا اللي هو
صلاح ياقوت نرجو الهدوء وكل طلباتكم
هتتنفذ ومعانا مناديب من الصليب الاحمر
ومعانا وزير الدفاع ورئيس الوزراء وكل
مطالبكم حنمر عليكم عنبر عنبر ونشوف
مطالبكم ايه يجي محاضر واحد محاضر اعمى
وجاي قاعد عمال عمال يتكلم على العلاقه
بين اللغه العربيه واللغه العبريه وان
احنا اد عم وان
احنا قرايب واللغه اهو شوفوا انتم بتقولوا
واحد احنا بنقول احاد انتم بتقولوا اثنين
احنا بنقولش شناين ولا مش عارف ايه شموني
مانيه انتوا بتقولوا كده
ف وقعد جايب مجموعه من الامثله كتير
وبعدين في الاخر يقعد يعيط ويقول يعني
احنا نفسنا ان احنا نعيش في امان احنا
نفسنا ان احنا نعيش في سلام انا نفسي نطلع
من الخنادق ان احنا نعيش مع
بعضينا الطريقه في في الكلام بطبع بشكل او
اخر لابد انها تسيب تاثير على الراجل
الاسير ده هوون اللي هم وضبوه بحيث ان هو
يقبل هذا الكلام اريدك ان يعني تتذكر لي
بعض الامثله ان كانت هناك امثله لمن يمكن
ان نسميهم ضحايا
لاساليب والتخطيط
الفكري النفسي من جانب الاسرائيليين سواء
في مراحل ال الهدم النفسي الاولى او في
اسلوب الخطاب بعد ذلك في
اساليب بعد ما رجعنا من الاثر وواقفين
في كنا هم سابونا في الكليه الحربيه شويه
يعني وقف واحد دكتور من الاسر يصلي وفجاه
بس راح بصص لربنا كده وقال ده عمايلك يا
ظالم
دهدي وانفجر عمال يتخانق في الصلاه مع
ربنا مش واحد بقى كل
الاسرى حتى الان عندهم مشاكل نفسيه بما في
ذلك انا
[موسيقى]
بالطب انا ماقبلش ان حد يمد ايده دلوقتي
مثلا لو كان عندي يلبس سجاير ايام ما كنت
بدخن يعني وياخد سيجاره من علبتي انا
اديله العلبه كلها لكن ياخد سيجار من
علبتي
لا ولما يعني انا مش بخيل يعني انا ممكن
ان لكن لما ابتديت افحص هذا الموضوع لقيت
ان السبب ان الراجل نتش من على عين
النظاره واصبحت دي موجوده لغايه دلوقتي
عندي اشياء كتيره جدا مشاكل نفسيه مش ممكن
سيرتك
[موسيقى]
ت اذا كان جانب من الاسرائيليين يستحق
اللعنه فان جانبا اخر يستحق الشكر فقط
عندما فتش هذا الرجل في الوثائق السريه
لوزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه عام
994 فقط عندما اهتمت بالموضوع بعدها بعام
كبريات الصحف الاسرائيليه بدانا نحن
نتحرك ام ترانا
تحركنا
اتدري شيئا لقد اثار رد الفعل المصري
فضولي لدي احساس بان الذي ضايقهم لم يكن
حقيقه ان جنودا اسرائيليين قتلوا اسرى حرب
مصريين لقد كانوا يعلمون ولم يكونوا بحاجه
الي او الى احد من
زملائي كي يخبرهم
بذلك اننا نحن الاسرائيليين مازلنا نبحث
عن جثث جنودنا في حرب
48 وهو شيء لا تجده في العالم العربي
فماذا اذا عساه يحدث لو طالب الشعب المصري
حكومته بالبحث عن ذويه ولذا لم ترغب
الحكومه المصريه في سماع المزيد وانما
قالت حسنا اعطونا تقريرا تعترفون فيه
بانكم اشرار وبان اخطاتم نعرضه على شعبنا
ودعوا الامر
ينتهي
اتصلنا بالسفير المصري في تل ابيب محمد
بسيوني طلبوا اسئله مكتوبه عن طريق الفاكس
بعثنا بها ثم اتصلنا مره اخرى جاءنا الرد
اعتذارا عن عدم
الحديث زي ما بيقول
المثل البلدي عندنا الباب ال بقت تيك منه
الريح سده
واستريح هو نوع من
العجز العجز انما جالي الرد عن طريق
الامانه العامه في مجلس الشعب الوزير
الخارجيه بيقوللي يعني بالنسبه
ل
المجرمين الذين ارتكبوا هذا الجرم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يعني
بتحقق في من هم من هم ايه ده هم بيحكموا
الان
اسرائيل يعني براك شخصيا الان احد هؤلاء
وبيز وماعرفش مين و وكل تانه نعم وانت
عارف الحاجات دي
كلها فاما
موضوع التعويضات فهو و موضوع محادثات بين
الحكومتين محادثات هي دي محادثات السلام
كمان هو كما تفضلت هي ليست قضيه دبلوماسيه
خالصه ولكنها مساله وطنيه بالدرجه الاولى
ولا نستطيع تناسيها لان الراي العام لا
ينساها لانها بتمس مساس عاطفي وانساني
وتاريخي وحضاري وبالتالي الخارجيه المصريه
تحركت منذ البدايه اولا على مستويين مستوى
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي ادى الى ان شكل
شيمون بريز رئيس الوزراء التالي لرابي في
نهايه عام 1995 لجنه اسرائيليه لبحث هذا
الموضوع وما سربه بعض الاسرائيليين عن
ذكرياتهم في الحرب 56 وحرب 67 هذه اللجنه
ظلت تبحث من 95 حسب معلوماتنا الى سنه 98
وانتهت الى تقرير يبدو انه تقرير يثبت عدم
وجود ادله وهذا متوقع طبعا من الجانب
الاخر ولكن لم نبلغ بشيء حتى
الان لا استطيع الاجابه الان فلا علم لي
بهذا التقرير ولم ارى اعلم انه موجود لكني
لم اقراه ولا استطيع
الاجابه توصل الجنرال المتقاعد اهارون
دورون الذي عينه رئيس الوزراء انذاك شمعون
بيز لكتابه التقرير توصل الى نتائج مشابهه
ما نشر وهي ان تم اسرى وئت معاملتهم وان
افعالا مشابهه ربما ايضا قام بها المصريون
ضضد الاسرائيليين رغم عدم وجود دليل على
ذلك رفع هذا التقرير برمته الى السلطات
المصريه وهي حره في الكشف عنه ونشره
انشءت
انا اعتقد ان الظروف ظروف الاحتلال
وظروف التطورات اللي على الساحه العالميه
وانك بتحارب عشان تستعيد ارضك وكل الحاجات
دي كلها ساهمت في هذا يعني لكن زي ما قال
عمرو موسى وسئل السؤال ده وقال لك ان هذه
القضيه الملف بتاع القضيه دي مفتوح وان
مصر لم تغلقه وهيجي الوقت اللي هيفتح زي
نهب ثروه سينا وبالتالي لا علاقه لهذا
الملف باحتمالات التسويه ومسيره السلام
هناك ملفات كثيره سوف تفتح ايضا اسرائيل
استنزفت بترول سيناء اسرائيل قامت بحفريات
اثريه في سيناء قس على هذا في كل ال الارض
العربيه المحتله انا امل ان يتركوا ذلك
ولكن اذا اصر اصرت الحكومه المصريه فليس
الباحثون لان الباحثون لا يمكن ان يروا
الاسرار الان الاسرار هذه م خبا من
الجانبين ولكن كما قلت اذا اصر اي طرف
مثلا الطرف المصري يستطيع بعد ذلك مع
الطرف الاسرائيلي مع المسؤولين وليس
الباحثين بالنسبه للجان تحكيك تشكل من قبل
حكومات وجان تحكيك تشكل من كيبل الحكومات
اسرائيليه لها لقب
عنا بسموها هذك الكلمه يمكن غير ملائمه
للتلفزيون بسموها لجن
غطا معناته غطا [__] او
او غطا على تهمه هذه الجان معناتها ان
تدفن القضيه مش تكشف القضيه وهذا يرجع حتى
الى لجنه تحكيك بعملو ال فساد داخلي
اسرائيلي مش فقط على
امور اسرائيليه عربيه اللي هي اكثر حساسا
انا ارى ان يتم تحريك الامر على على مستوى
المحافل الدوليه وان تقوم بذلك لجنه شعبيه
مصريه تتبناها نقابه المحامين تتبناها
احدى منظمات حقوق الانسان التي تملا مصر
انا يا ريت لو في اراده عربيه الان من
للاسف لا توجد يا ريت يبقى فيه دير ياسين
يبقى فيه كفر قاسم يبقى فييه قانا يبقى
فيه بحر البقر يبقى في طائره سلوى حجازي
يبقى في اسرى 67 يعني يبقى في نوع مما
فعله الصهاينه بنا كعرب وليس كمصريين ما
انا قلت يعني لابد من توفر الاراده اراده
سياسيه تعتقد بصحه وبمصداقية
[موسيقى]
في محاكمه والاعتذار لمصر وللشعب العربي
بشكل عام على هذه الجرايم والتعويض لاسر
الضحايا بلا شك يجب اذا مصر في وقت من
الاوقات اقترحت فكره الاعتزار
والتعويض هذا شيء اخلاقي اساسي في
العلاقات بين اي
واحد بين اي اي اي اي ناس انه اذا في
اقتراح لازم اسرائيل توافق وتشكر مصر حتى
على هذا الاقتراح لانه اقتراح ايجابي وهذا
زي الر الرماز الاخضر تقول مصر لاسرائيل
تفضلوا امشوا هي مهدنا الطريق فاذهبوا الى
تسامح واذا اسرائيل رفضت هذا الاقتراح هذا
غلط عظيم لا لا افهم معناته من ينسح
لرؤساء الحكومه الاسرائيل بشؤون العربيه
فلم يعلمون وين عايشين فهم يمكن يجب عليهم
ان يكونوا مستشارين شؤون امريكيه وليس
شؤون عربيه يعني اي واحد بعرف الاقليه
العربيه والحياه اللي شرق الاسديه والشرف
العربي والشرف الانساني مش عربي لازم ان
يقبل هذا الاقتراح بايد مفتوحه ويقوله يا
م اهلا وسهلا انا مستعد بكره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا بشيء من هذه الروح مؤمنا بان له حقا
اخذ منه عنوه بالقوه قرر الاسير المصري
المنسي كغيره ان يستعيده عنوه
بالقانون يقتات اليوم واسرته ممتده على
فتاه سياره اجره هو نفسه اجير
عليها افلت بها ذات يوم من زحام القاهره
الى زحام المحاكم فاقام عام 95 دعوه
قضائيه امام محكمه جنوب القاهره بحق اسحاق
رابين وايريل شارون والقاتل المعترف ارييه
بيرو يعني انا الوقت ده سبب ان انا رفعت
دعوه على اسرائيل ان انا كنت في السعوديه
وكنت لاجل حظي في شركه نقل حجاج ادت
اتوبيسات للجيش السعودي كان بينقل بها
اسرى عراقيين من الحدود لمنطقه في
السعوديه اسمها الارطاويه في المنطقه ديت
شفت معامله الجيش السعودي للاسير العراقي
كان بيدي لهم خرفان يذبحوا وياكلوا لحمه
مشويه ويدو لهم يشربوا سجاير ويدو لهم كل
حاجه وكانوا عايشين احسن عيشه فقلت الله
طب وانا طب انا كنت اسير عند اسرائيل ما
عملوني كده ليه والله لارفع عليهم
قضيه لكن دعوه امين عبد الرحمن رفضت على
الفور كما رفض غيرها بحجه عدم
الاختصاص قضيته بين يدي الله ومعذبه بين
يدي الشيطان وهذه الدعوه بين يدي الدوله
بحكم مسؤوليتك كرئيس لهيه قضايا الدوله
بدات استعد
ل فيما لو طلبت من الدوله رفع اقامه هذه
الدعوه فبدات اجمع ما جزء من اللي بيتصل
بالموضوع ف اولها اتفاقيه جنا في سنه 49
وتعديلها اللي تم سنه 68 وكل ما
نشر من مقالات او ابحاث في الموضوع ده
جمعته وعملت فايل احتياطي من يومها انتظر
محامي الدوله تلك المكالمه الهاتفيه
بالتكليف
مر اكثر من خمس سنوات نسى هو نفسه انه كان
في انتظار
مكالمه
انظر لو اراد مواطن مصري او عائله مصريه
مقاضاه احد فلا احد يمنعهم انه قرارهم لو
شعروا بان الحق معهم فليفعل لا يجب عليهم
الخضوع لاي اوامر سياسيه للقيام بذلك انه
قرارهم ربما القضاء الاسرائيلي قد يجد
المنفذ لتقديم هؤلاء المجرمين حتى وان كان
الزمن قد اخذ على هذه الجريمه الكثير
الكثير ولكن هذا الموضوع يجب ان نضعه امام
القضاء الاسرائيلي ليقول كلمته وان كان
القانون القانون هو في الاساس تفسير روح
القانون لما احنا بصدد اتفاقيه دوليه
فاللي بيحكم التقدم فيها احكام هذه
الاتفاقيه فاذا كانت الاتفاقيه تقول ما
فيش تقادم يبقى النص القانون الاسرائيلي
لا يطبق لان احنا بنحكم او بنطالب بحقنا
قبالهم استنادا لاحكام الاتفاقيه وليس
استنادا لاحكام القانون
الاسرائيلي لا في النظام
الاسرائيلي انه هناك
تقادم على جرائم بعد سنوات عديده ولذلك لا
يمكن محاكمته و لكن يمكن استخلاص العبر اي
اذا كان اذا كان
مسؤوليه لمسؤول اسرائيلي سواء قائد كبير
او ضابط صغير انت تتحدث عن مفهوم التقادم
مفهوم التقادم ينسحب في القانون ولكنه لا
ينسحب على جرائم الحرب واذكر الاسرائيليين
انفسهم بان جرائم النازي ضد اليهود لم
تسقط بالتقادم كيف تسقط جرائمهم في الحرب
ضدنا بالتقادم
هم انفسهم لم ينسوا من قاموا ضدهم باعمال
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه وحتى الان
لازالوا يتعقبون بالمطارده القانونيه
والسياسيه فلماذا يحل لهم ما يحرم
عليه اعتقد بل انصحك بوضع حد لهذه
المقارنه الغبيه الشنيعه
فورا لا انصحك
بالتوقف مفهوم
اوكي شوف البجاحه البجاحه انه بيرفع قضيه
لاسترداد
دكان ومش مهم عنده الناس اللي اللي ذبحهم
وقتلهم وبعدين انت عمال تقول لي ديمقراطيه
في اسرائيل وحضاريه اين هي الحضاريه اين
حقوق الانسان اللي يعمل العمليه جريمه زي
دي يبقى ايه يبقى يعني انسان متوحش لا
يمكن انسان انك تيجي واحد اسير معهوش سلاح
وتقتله وبعدين تقول لي حضاري حضاري منين
الجندي النفر او الضابط
او الموظف الذي يقوم
باي عمل قد يكون نتيجته اضرار
للاخرين فاذا كان هذا العمل قام به وفقا
لامر
ا فهذا الامر يعطيه ايضا الحصانه بعدم
تقديمه للقضاء في القضايا التعويض الماده
12 من اتفاقيه جنيف في سنه 49 بتقول يقع
اسرى الحرب تحت سلطه الدوله المعاديه لا
تحت سلطه افراد او الوحدات العسكريه التي
اثارتها نعم معنى هذا ان الدعوه هترفع ضد
الحكومه الاسرائيليه سواء كان الضابط او
العسكري اللي ارتكب الفعل المؤسم عايش او
مات ا اذا بدنا نعمل هذه المقارنات
اسرائيل طالبت من المانيا في فتره ما
اعتراف بالجرائم هون في اعتراف را
بالجرائم الحرب
قذره لو كانت مصر قد احتلت اسرائيل فانني
متاكد من ان الاف الالاف من الاطفال
والنساء كانوا سيقتلون
ويغتصبون الجميع يعلم
ذلك لو حدث وقام هؤلاء الفلسطينيون
باحتلال اسرائيل سيكون هناك حمام من
الدم الجبهه السوريه عام 73 وفي مصر لم
يجدوا حتى اليوم لا الجنود ولا
جثثهم فاسرائيل
تحاول بطرق دبلوماسيه وبواسطه العالم ان
تتحدث عن المسؤولين في سوريا ولبنان ومصر
من اجل التعاون
لايجاد هذا جثث او او لايجاد هؤلاء الجنود
احياء كنت داخل قميص من الجيبس رجلي وذراع
اليسرى وقضيت وقتا طويلا في الحبس
الانفرادي ومنعوا عني احيانا الطعام
والماء ومررت بجميع انواع ما يوصف
بالتعاملات الجسديه لاجبار على اجابه
الاسئله لقد كانت تلك حقا فتره عصيبه من
حياتي لا يستحيل هذا استطيع ان اؤكد ان من
تقاليد العسكريه المصريه العريقه صاحبه
التاريخ الطويل احترام الاتفاقيات الدوليه
واحترام اسرى الحرب فلا يمكن لمجرد اعتراف
احد الطرفين بجريمه معينه ان يكون رده رد
هجومي على الجانب الاخر واتهامه بنفس
الشيء بغير سند ولا دليل اصل يعني انا
عاوزين ننبه
لشيء السلام ليس لحظات هانئه السلام
اجراءات تفاهم على مصالح مشتركه من مصلحتي
ان اسرائيل ما تطلعش في تصوري شويه مجرمين
ومن مصلحتها ايضا ومن مصلحتي اقول لناسي
اذا في شخص ارتكب جريمه هذا الشخص بيحاسب
ظروف كانت كذا واعتذروا بكذا
ول انا ابني مات شهيد على الارض دي ازاي
ارح لهم برجليا انا معاك وانا معاك انا و
يا غير مقتنع قناعه كامله باي متر تقوم
عليه
اسرائيل ولكن اذا قبلنا هذا
المر فعلينا ان نقبله
بلا انقاص
لكرامتنا عندما تضمن الامه
العربيه اننا في سلام مع
اسرائيل ليس خوفا منها وانما هو شرف عروبه
قولي والله انا مضيت معاهم وش انفذ قوي
كده قوي انا مضيت معاهم ودي هدنه اقوللك
اه هي هدنه اه طب ايه الاهمال بتاعك ده من
فضلك يلا ادهنلي الازاز ازرق يلا اعمل لي
الحيطان قدام البيوت يلا اعمل لي تجنيد
اجباري للبشر يلا اعملي اقتصاد حرب وا
اللي تتهمك لا مؤاخذه انك كداب في كله
وانك مش مهتم بحاجه وبتنصيب على الشعب
المصري يا جماعه احنا مش عايزين مشاكل مش
عايزين مشاكل احنا في رطه السلام سلام ده
اللي احنا عايزينه وهم كمان عاوزينه هم مش
عايزينه احنا اللي قدمناه احنا اللي
بداناه خدنا قصاده ايه ده امر واقع يتغير
لما تلاقي سيده تبكي في نهايه المصرحيه
وتقابلني معها بناتها فتقول لي انا مبسوطه
لان لقيت ولادي بيبكوا على شيء الخطوره في
دول الخطوره في دول الذين لم يحاربوا هذا
العدو ولم يدركوا الخطر القادم من هذا
العدو الخطوره في دول اللي هم طلعوا وقدم
لهم النمط الغربي والنمط الامريكي بالذات
امركه كل شيء بالنسبه لهم هي الخلاص
الوحيد وهي المخرج الوحيد انا بسال نفسي
وانا لست من دعاه الحروب ولا دموي ولا
ارهابي ولا اي حاجه يعني بسال نفسي ان
احتاجت مصر في يوم ما ان تدافع عن نفسها
من سيدافع عنها ما تتكلم يا استاذ فكري
يا مساله قاسيه فعلا بس ده كان زمان الوضع
دلوقتي اختلف بقى في اتفاق ملعون ابده
اتفاق لو اللي ماتوا دول كانوا الثمن
[موسيقى]
لا تتعلق قضيه اسرانا في حروبنا مع
اسرائيل بما مضى بقدر ما تتعلق بما هو ات
اي مثال نقدمه للاجيال القادمه اذا ما هي
اضطرت يوما ما الى حمل السلاح من يحمي
ظهرها ومن يضمن لك ان سهما اتاني من الخلف
لن يجيئك من الف خلف من حق اسرائيل ان
تحاول دائما كسر شوكه الولاء في قلوبنا
ومن حقنا ولو احيانا ان نقاوم فما الصلح
الا معاهده بين ندين في شرف القلب لا
تنتقص اقلب الغريب كقلب اخيك اعينا عينا
اخيك وهل تتساوى يد سيفها كان لك بيد
سيفها
اثكلك ان سهما اتاني من الخلف
سوف يجيئك من الف
خلف انا عاوز اقول كذا رساله عاوز اقول
اول رساله للشهداء اللي كانوا
معايا واللي موتتهم اسرائيل عزل من السلاح
عرايا
عطاشه واللي موتتهم اسرائيل من ضمنهم
اخويا اقول لهم الله يرحمكم دي واحده
وعاوز
اقول لكل العالم يبصوا للقضيه ديت كده
ويعرفوا يا اسرائيل عملت ايه وعاوز اقول
لحكام
اسرائيل اذا مسكت اي اسير من اي دوله
عربيه سواء كان فلسطيني من جنوب لبنان من
حزب الله من منظمه امل من الاردن من سوريا
من اي حته احترمه احترمه كادم يا اخي
احترمه كادم عشان الدول الثانيه
تحترمك الدول الثانيه تحترمك لما انت
تحترم الاسير تبقى دوله الدول الثانيه تح
احترمك وعاوز
اقول برض للحكام بتوعنا الله يعينكم الله
يعينكم في اللي انتم فيه ده في مفاوضات
السلام من ناحيه وفي ده من ناحيه وفي
الحاجات دي انا مش عارف هم مستحملين ازاي
انا بستغرب يعني الراجل الحسن مبارك ده
الله يكون في عونه مستحمل استحمال انا انا
بعذره يعني لو انا منه ما استحملش ما
استحملش هو ده عنده جلد فظيع وعاوز اقول
لرجاله القوات المسل المصريه ما تنسوش ان
انتم خير الاجناد في
[موسيقى]
الارض